[Music]
this guy his name is Peter he's 37 he is
such a great guy ooh cuz at the age of
35 he realized that he was doing really
well for himself
oh wait by the way he migrated to
America after running away at the age of
10 from his abusive family he he settled
in Oklahoma he started working at World
Vision United States which is a global
Christian humanitarian organization that
helps children in need so by the time he
was 35 he realized he was doing really
well for himself he had two extra rooms
in his home and so he decided to become
a foster dad this single foster dad and
over the past few years he had fostered
12 kids ranging from the age of 2 or
from 2 to 11
and since he's single he's only able to
care for 2 children at a time but then
there was this one kid who came into his
life so Anthony he had been abandoned by
his birth parents at the age of 2 and so
he was taken in by this other family who
served as church elders so they adopted
him and then when he was 11 they dropped
him off at a hospital and never picked
him up and so that he ended up getting
abandoned again and that's when he
that's when Peter picked up Anthony
he was only supposed to have him for a
weekend to like foster him for a weekend
but then once we heard his story and
like he like they just felt like a
connection he decided to adopt Anthony
and so now they that he's his adoptive
dad and they had the cutest relationship
ever
who is Peter oh good he's Channel yeah
Anthony and he's a kid who got dumped a
bunch yeah the kid and so um I don't
know the history like their story is
just really sweet and they share like he
shares a lot of being a foster dad on
Instagram but particularly this story is
touched the media and stuff because
they've been
reporting a lot about the story and the
fact that you know just based off of one
weekend and how this kid had gone have
been abandoned it's just really sweet
that that Peter decided to take him in
and like be his dad it's cool I'm like
good
that's a grown-ass man we held as a kid
now he's 13 I hope he doesn't mind that
little [ __ ] win at Connect four just
clear this up boy that's not a good like
a lesson for life that's horrible yeah I
won't let my daughter win a [ __ ] yeah
that's how my dad was maybe beat up so
that prepared for life I trip I trip the
[ __ ] out of my daughter every time like
in the house I will just clip the it's
not like just like sticking the foot out
I would like literally sweep the leg do
you tell to jump in the air first no no
I just do it while she's on the speck
like literally just walk by this spooked
if go back what the [ __ ] Xbox Kira the
plane we have to share control thirds is
pretty intuitive I was waiting for like
the other shoe to drop like I thought it
was knowing me like some [ __ ] up [ __ ]
so like the whole time you're talking
about it I'm like my ass cheeks oh yeah
I'm ready
it was three seconds for one we have a
nice story just one time I don't like to
say this [ __ ] halo game I'll tell you
that probably halo 5 yeah I gave a [ __ ]
they're probably the ones in the lobby
saying that they [ __ ] your mother cute
and stuff but they didn't show the dad
struggling to figure out the controls
and how to play the game and throw in
the control against the wall couch co-op
because there is none so they probably
had to share control because there's no
couch co-op
Thank You halo 5 [ __ ] you Microsoft
that's all well Ted the Dodgers lost and
we couldn't change the channel listen
I'd [ __ ] pisses me off like nothing
else beautiful tradition Microsoft and
family we do miss seriously what's
freaking hate it I do why why you'll
never blame thank you couch co-op was
like my [ __ ] childhood what does
couch co-op let's go up okay so you have
kids but I guess they don't get treated
that well
it's when you can sit with like your dad
or your brother and you guys can play a
game together on the same screen but the
split-screen right let's see your kids
were deprived of that obviously and so
they'll provide a rather warm feeling of
playing cop school now what they do with
the stupid games is that if you want to
play with someone else has to be online
with a stranger somewhere halfway across
the world or YouTube or you to buy
multiple consoles in the same house
nobody can [ __ ] do that [ __ ] and then
split-screen your [ __ ] locally know was
where it's at well I mean we have three
places and three X boxes of no I don't
want to touch our controller she can't
just - oh that's why we have something
then we have one in the guest one of the
game console we have multiple with the
game yeah absolutely
well you gotta have one for the bathroom
of Ellen's suite and one for the
remainder of the office hour I mean a TV
in your shower no does the TV's embedded
in the wall with the plexi huh what TV
handle can tvs handle one of these days
like water I don't know after this
corona outbreak how many of those TVs
can you keep we mean how many can I keep
you know cuz all those getting cancelled
you know well Netflix are still up and
so a little as well as that Wow
but TVs you have to keep it just a flex
I don't speak broke so I don't I can't
hear anything that anyone say too many
air bubbles under a hundred in this
wallet right now he's the one who [ __ ]
is his garbage was a walk-on you didn't
here's you know the walnuts cuz he's so
he's so Apple pay
this is my business
[Music]
[Laughter]
I would be hired if I pay mustard laws
and I'm just like [ __ ] you I'm not payin
another day and it was like it was like
Credit Karma it's like your score has
changed I was like look don't act like
this is a good thing i'ma give you like
a sad face at least attention
no it just is Vegas like your score has
changed I'm just not good like just my
account I mean until I saw using my
degree which I won't I'm not yeah
Business Administration with emphasis on
entrepreneurship and a minor in
marketing
if you're a real entrepreneur you're
dropped out of college you wouldn't have
to pay student loan debt
you're right you right to that yeah yeah
oh yeah I didn't do a lot of work though
because I was [ __ ] one in
administrators so I didn't have to go to
all my classes I know someone who
majored in percussion ISM what somebody
majoring there like literary arts like
just talked to a guy didn't major in
claymation was two years ago
climax [ __ ] a robot chicken I mean he
bragged about it it was in the sender
profile in my dumbass hit okay I'll try
it I think I just had questions honestly
you like girl I'm gonna make you a base
I'm like am i weird cuz I find that
pretty dope hobby I guarantee he doesn't
have an 813 tips for finding it wait
till we cut a major percussion dude I
gotta say the wife's movie I've ever
seen is that [ __ ] movie it's a great
movie it's a great movie it's a you
[ __ ] zoom out it's about a guy who's
stressed about drumming and that's funny
no it's about a guy who stressed about
his pastor I showed my wife that movie
cuz I'm like I need you to understand
this is how I look at my career like I
felt that I there have been times I was
like you know what I shouldn't be in
relationship I really should just focus
on this because I can't I can't serve
two masters like and all I want to do is
work and that's right to hear your wife
is your master well I mean she is she
deserves the time and energy of that
that a mastership she's not given that
but she no she's not the medicine she
understands the hierarchy of the house
and she respects in that supporters it
supports me but she knows like dick is
long to hear hear
here's here's my joke here's nothing
here's my problem is that the movie in
the movie
I don't by the way that the cat gets
talk right so so the teachers like hate
to hear okay you're stand-up comic tell
me a joke tell me a joke go ahead right
now you're staircar right nobody does
this [ __ ] happened actually I will say
this I I have been to like some cuz I
was I got to bed my entire life since
middle school I've been in like concert
marching all city band Basin I'm sorry
bass and snare drum Alto Alto okay it
gets to this snare job alto tenor sax
regular and bass clarinet it's the
regular stress I've seen I've seen band
directors get very irate I've seen them
throw stuff I've seen them throw chairs
like that's not what the [ __ ] we do what
are we practicing for and that's what
the [ __ ] you gonna do and then we go
outside and we watch it and like what
you have like were you doing that court
choreography and like you're on the
[ __ ] field like that [ __ ] gets
intense bro I've seen band directors
call students bitch-ass [ __ ] oh the
band directed was white the student was
Asian I was like
is all Odin we shouldn't have been such
a oneness yeah but yeah it gets it gets
intense man so I will say that it might
have seemed extreme for somebody that
has never really been in that world like
that but like bandit I getting very sick
I just thought to me it was a big bang
my band instructor Awards every year and
he would get really pissed if he was a
big just like movies no girls the
Casablanca next you're gonna tell me
like snape kills dumbledore some [ __ ] Oh
spoilers I watch that movie I don't even
know that reference
[Music]
[Music]